are so here in the great evergreen state
we are having what some people are
calling Snowmageddon I drove through
this winter wonderland of ice and
death to go see underworld awakening if
anyone says that I have jacked up stupid
out of black priorities
I can't much argue them because they're
absolutely right
underworld awakening all right so I saw
the trailer to Underworld Awakening and
I was like why is that happening this
movie kind of looked like it had no
relevance whatsoever after seeing the
movie I actually feel like this movie
had no relevance whatsoever alright so
in the second underworld underworld
evolution which is actually my favorite
of the series we left off where
curviness gave Selene a gift the gift
she can now be like a daywalker like
blade and that's where it ends so it's
like oh where's it gonna take the series
it's gonna be in a whole new direction
it's gonna be awesome she's gonna be a
daywalker and it's just gonna be great
nope not actually not at all this movie
starts out with like a montage of
backstory and it's not really backstory
of underworld 1 & 2 so much as it is a
montage filling you in and what happened
after underworld 2 to now what happened
you ask well human beings found out
about vampires and lichens so now there
are task forces that go out and
eliminate them they call it the great
purging I'm not ruining anything because
this is actually in the montage at the
very beginning of the movie
now underworld awakening takes place
like 12 or 13 years after that check
this bit of false advertising out here
is the description of underworld
awakening when human forces discover the
existence of vampire and Lycan clans a
war to eradicate both species commences
the vampire warrior s Selene leads the
battle against humankind no that is not
the plot of this movie that's the
two-minute backstory they give you
before this movie you know the one that
has nothing to do with this movie false
advertising right there the plot of this
movie there's a little girl that the
Lycans want Selene needs to protect her
that's it the plot of this movie has
nothing to do with core Venus the plot
of this movie has nothing to do with
Lucian the plot of this movie has
nothing to do with Celine's past it kind
of feels like the new x-files movie
where you're like yeah that just feels
like an episode of a TV show it's like
if underworld was a TV show this would
be one of the episodes that would be
seen as filler not really relevant the
things should just kind of happen which
is code for saying the last three
underworld movies are absolutely
irrelevant to this one it seems weird
but that's what it is this movies
directed by a couple of guys and it
seems like these guys are big video game
fans example there's the same where
these likens or fighting vampires
alright all good and dandy Selene take
some of them out that's cool oh and then
a really big like and enters the room
and she has to fight this enormous Lycan
this thing's like 2 or 3 times bigger
than any Lycan you've ever seen which
made me think video game boss which is
how it was you know you take
the little guys and you got to fight the
really big one and now it's a big boss
battle just video game it irritated
me video games are cool but not this
time
I looked these two directors up on IMDB
turns out their last movie has a zero
percent on Rotten Tomatoes so I'm not
saying Rotten Tomatoes is the end-all
be-all of human existence in terms of
rating movies but I am saying when I
watched this movie and looked into what
they did before I was not surprised in
the least that their movie had a zero
percent on Rotten Tomatoes it's all I'm
saying I don't know who this movie is
actually going to appeal to if you're an
underworld fan you're going to hate it
because it's butchering the underworld
lore that you've come to love if you're
not an underworld fan but you are a
movie fan you're going to hate it
because it's not well done at all so
that just leaves people who like
videogames in their movies in the
end if we're talking about video games
this is like the bad video game chapter
that was made by a completely different
crew that you don't actually count as
part of the video game series that you
love so Underworld Awakening is the
first movie of 2012 to get the
prestigious award of dog this is
just some irrelevant ass movie that has
the main character from the underworld
movies and vampires and likens that
don't matter so your favorite underworld
movie what is it comment below let me
know or if you don't like underworld
your favorite vampire or werewolf movie
vampires and werewolves they're badass
just ask my Magic the Gathering decks
dude I've got a vampire deck and a
werewolf deck tear apart
yeah I'm nerdy I told you that and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more